you're looking at a shot of New York
City this morning where there are very
few cars on the street for this part of
town you had a meeting today you be able
to get to it but no one's got any
meetings because you're working from
home and school is also shut all over
the country the school system here in
New York City the nation's largest is
closed starting today and in all 33
different states are closing public
schools all to stop the spread of the
corona virus at least thirty two and a
half million students are affected Meg
Oliver joins us from her house she's in
Montclair New Jersey where her children
are also home and there they are the
whole family made good morning how are
you handling this how our parents coping
yeah right wait we should probably ask
my husband this is stressful but this is
the new normal across America I've got
Cormack and Maria here logged into their
online classes sorry Fred you've ran
into that wall there and then over here
Tommy he's doing his math homework now
we just bought these laptops a couple
days ago we didn't have a choice really
a lot of students cannot afford that and
that is a huge concern for as Moore
school shut down it's gonna be very
difficult for a lot of families New York
City Mayor Bill de Blasio announced
Sunday that the city's public schools
will be closed until at least April 20th
possibly even longer the closures come
as the CDC says closing for at least
eight weeks may help mitigate the
viruses spread Olivia Austin is an
eighth grade social studies teacher in
Newark New Jersey where schools are
closed throughout the state the school
offers security that they thrive off of
so just not having that sense of
security I think is also an added stress
Austin is concerned that our students
could fall behind and their curriculum
one of the biggest challenges is that I
work in an inner-city school and a lot
of our students don't have access to
laptops another concern at the top of
educators Minds providing meals to
students who rely on school lunches as
their primary source of nutrition in
Virginia the Arlington public school
system started a grab-and-go initiative
where students will be able to pick up
breakfast and lunch bags well schools
remain out of session for the next
for weeks about 30% of our students in
Arlington participate in the free and
reduced meals program so I do think that
there would be students who had nothing
to eat tomorrow for breakfast we need
more than you know 12 to 24 hours to
plan for the complete disruption of not
just our lives but the lives of children
Kristen little is a single mom with two
kids who are expected to be at home for
the next month at a minimum my first
reaction when I got the notification
that they were going to shudder at the
school score money was instant
overwhelming anxiety and I broke into
tears because you're just completely not
mentally or physically prepared for
something like that
now school officials in New York City
only have a few hours left to make sure
that emergency responders and health
care workers have access to childcare
Gayle Meg looks like you and husband
John have it under control right now
it's a lead 20 I know Thank You Meg
thank you very much for letting us come
over